salut bienvenue dans ce nouveau mental
vlog c'est toujours une vidéo par jour
pendant un an et le jeudi je vous parle
un petit peu de ce que je veux et je
vais couper mon téléphone vous en ai
parlé ce samedi qu'aujourd'hui j'avais
envie de parler des grandeurs non
linéaire ça me fait marrer les grandeurs
non linéaire je sais que comme ça ça
ressemble pas trop une blague bien
rigolade mais c'est drôle je vous assure
qu'on peut rire avec ça le côté vraiment
amusant des grandeurs non linéaire c'est
que notre cerveau seul euro présente
très mal de gens d'une manière générale
se représenter les grandes quantités on
sait pas trop faire en fait parce que ça
touche pas à notre réalité ça devient
tout de suite abstrait quand on parle de
millions de particules on se représente
pas en fait ce que c'est un million de
choses par un million d'euros et les
grandeurs non linéaire ce sont des
grandeurs qui montrent de façon
exponentielle
je vous ai donc préparé deux exemples
qui sont assez drôles pour mériter
d'être dans cette vidéo le premier c'est
que vous pouvez aller de la terre à la
lune avec une feuille de papier
avec ça vous pouvez faire le trajet
terre-lune en tout cas vous pouvez
couvrir cette distance là le trajet de
la terre à la lune il est de 380 3000
les quelques kilomètres des comme je
sais pas je regardais sur internet et
j'étais pas loin c'est 384000 403 km on
n'est pas un millier de kilomètres près
non plus on peut en clients cette
feuille quelquefois couvrir la distance
terre-lune faut quand même savoir qu'il
est difficile de plier une feuille de
papier plus de 8 fois pour faire le test
un éclair 7 6 là j'en suis à 6 fois et
déjà pour moi ça devient compliqué de le
plier plus un par contre si vous
regardez on voit qu'en six fois ça a
pris une grosse épaisseur
alors que tout départ ma feuille de
papier le faisait à peu près de 0,1 mm
0,1 mm sais rien mais une fois que les
plis bien en deçà double donc ça fait
0,2 mm mais une fois que j'ai repliée en
2000 ça fait 0 4 mm sa double donc ça
fait 0 8 mm donc sa double ça fait un
gain de 6 cm donc sa double ça fait 3 2
cm donc sa double ça fait 6 4 cm et
c'est ça si j'arrivais à plier cette
feuille de papier 42 x 42 x c'est quand
même une grandeur qu'on arrive à se
présentez-nous mentalement en 42 fois ça
ferait 440 mille kilomètres environ 440
me km environ se dire on toucherait la
terre à la lune
bon autant vous dire qu'à force de plier
ce serait tout petit comme ça serait
comme un cheveux même plus petit qu'un
cheveu au niveau de l'épaisseur mais on
couvrirait la distance encadrante deux
fois un autre exemple qui vient d'un
compte d'une légende on sait pas si
c'est vrai ou pas vrai c'est les
chéquiers de 6 à 6,6 mais chéquier de si
ça vaut mieux pas avoir un cheveu sur la
langue pour raconter cette histoire est
effectuée tcd ses pieds de fifa fait les
chéquiers de chicha non c'est les
chéquiers de 6 à à peu près 3000 ans
avant jésus-christ le roi belle équipe
s'ennuyer il s'ennuie et terriblement et
il avait promis une grande récompense on
savait pas forcément laquelle une énorme
récompense à qui lui proposerait un
divertissement digne de son intérêt de
rouen le sache si ça vous plaît beaucoup
plus évident à dire le chef pas message
6 a entendu parler de ça entendu parler
de la récompense surtout et donc il va
en roi belchite pour lui présenter le
jeu d'échecs donc avec un échiquier et
le jeu d'échecs lui a pris le jeu de la
guerre le rebelle qui adorent à ce
divertissement à doha ce jeu ici se mit
à y jouer vraiment il se mit à qui fait
ça je suis pas sûr que le roi ait dit je
kiffe mais vous comprenez l'idée et le
roi demande à ossages ce qu'il voulait
en récompense le sage a dit c'est très
simple je veux pas grand chose je veux
que vous remplissiez mon échiquier de
grains de riz et pour ça sur la première
case ou mettez un grain de riz sur la
deuxième vous en mettez deux fois plus
que sur la première case sur la 3eme
deux fois plus à chaque case comme ça
vous doublez vos doubler le nombre de
grains de riz qu'ils avaient sur la case
précédent et aux rebelles qui me dit oui
il n'avait pas vu ma vidéo encore le
rebelle qui ben ils pouvaient pas savoir
ce qui allait se passer
il a est terminée un clairement il ya 64
cases sur un échiquier donc sur la
première case ya un grain de riz sur la
deuxième il y aura deux sur la troisième
y en a quatre la quatrième il y en a
huit et si vous faites le calcul
arrivé à la 64e case il y aura deux
puissances 63 grain de riz encore une
valeur qu'on a du mal à se représenter
mentalement depuis 163 grain de riz ça
fait 9 milliards 2 milliards de grains
degré et de ce jour le
si ça se fit appeler uncle ben's satar
fola n'a pas été vérifiée quand même
méfiez-vous passion donc au total sur le
chéquier il y avait 18 milliards de
milliards de grains de riz à peu près
vous rendez compte c'est énorme
encore une fois je sais qu'on a du mal à
se représenter cette valeur 18 milliards
de milliards de grains de riz c'est à
peu près la production mondiale de
grains de riz qu'il y aurait sur mille
années est malin le sache si ça voilà
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu si
c'est le cas pensez à laisser un petit
pouce en l'air ça montre en fait à tout
youtube que vous aimez cette vidéo
pensez surtout à vous abonner à la
chaîne ça c'est très important comme ça
on s'abonne tous ensemble parce qu à
2500 abonnés
j'ai prévu une grande surprise pour où
on va se faire un live tous ensemble
durant des heures et des heures un apéro
live virtuel chacun chez soi mais tous
ensemble
rendez vous aussi dans les ca pour mon
spectacle fabien olicard vous mentalise
où les hallucinations collectives du 28
mars qui ont lu à paris et d'ici là
rendez vous demain à 17 heures pour le
prochain mentale vlog ciao